okay welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk but if you have
questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end uh second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audience
um therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out uh finally
The Talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel that's
about it now let me briefly introduce
our speaker today it is an honor to host
Professor Yan Chan in mathematics
department at University of
massachusetts. mouth Yan received his
PhD in uh mathematics from school of
mathematics University of min OTA in
2007 he then worked as a post doctoral
researcher at Brown University before
joining the department of ma mathematics
at University of Massachusetts that that
math in August
2010 where he currently served as a full
Professor Dr Chen's research has been
supported by the NSF afos Sr and onr via
University of Massachusetts DM must
program uh his research interest are in
numerical analysis and scientific
Computing in particular finite element
methods Ru basis methods and other fast
algorithms uncertain of quantification
design and Analysis for machine learning
algorithms he has graduated five
doctoral students and initiated the um
university of M massachusett
mouthmouth is accomplished program via
an NSF Grant to provide students in need
Financial social and uh curricular
support today yanai will talk about GPT
pin and tgp
tpin uh generative pre-trained physics
informed General Network toward
non-intrusive meta learning of
parametric PDS please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk now let me ask a couple
of question uh to yanai just to get to
know you better uh and make this seminar
um somewhat informal so first question
here we go um obviously you are
passionate about scientific machine
learning uh when and how did you get
into this field and started to do
research on them uhuh um thank you first
of all for that's a long bio and a long
title thank you for for reciting them I
appreciate it um so I've have been
working on reduce basis method and uh
which is by self machine learning is
algorithm so I sort of know the the the
the machine learning uh U field a bit
even without doing you know explicitly
the maybe a more um modern scientific
machine learning uh projects um so it
has been in my in my in my mind to work
on uh I see I saw some connections to
work on you know the new network
specific uh stuff um for a few years and
and and uh and I started uh working on
it together with a student Sean
uh about U two years ago two less than
three years ago so I'm a I'm a newcomer
here I'm looking forward to learning
from you know all the
experts okay great and and second
question is you're passionate about the
teaching and mentoring students right um
so if you can you know share some you
know thought about you know how why and
why why you enjoy it you know mentoring
students and you know teaching them and
Etc that would be awesome as a
professor um I think part of it is maybe
self-centered uh to be honest um uh I
when I get excited about the stuff that
I teach um so when when I when I when
I'm able to enunciate what what what I
saw this concept is about I got my
excited myself um I think you know
anecdotes points to that that that side
of that kind of excitement uh uh uh um
is somewhat contagious to students
students get excited to and and uh and
you know and of course in the more
traditional stuff you know we put in the
work and you see progress from students
um you most of the time it's probably a
bit hard and challenging like just like
research you have setbacks but you know
once a while once in once while you'll
see a great uh progress and that make it
all the whole effort worthwhile so I
think that's you know seeing that growth
see um undergraduate level and graduate
level uh that that that's um that's what
this profession is about and I I truly
enjoyed the
unit sounds wonderful all right the
stage is
yours all right um thank you so much
yome for inviting me to to this seminar
thank you for your work in doing this uh
ddps seminar and and uh uh and giving me
the opportunity to talk to your audience
I certainly uh treasure this
opportunity um I I today I was
reflecting on the uh the luck that I had
last year last June meeting one of your
group member Tony CH I'm not sure I
don't see the audience I'm not sure if
he's here but I appreciate um talking to
him last year at at at uh Morgan State
he here here so as y all right as Yong
just announced um so I'm going to talk
to you about GPD pin and tgpd pin today
and um I I I have to you know admit that
the title is somewhat um somewhat of a
gimmick but um I I think it's literally
true um you you hopefully you you'll be
convinced so this is join the walk the
most I will spend most of time talking
about um the the the the the gptp which
is a linear reduction method in the in
the pin fashion um so let's say the
linear part um I spend a few slides
towards the end uh to to talk about the
the extension to the nonlinear part and
um the first part part is join work with
Sean kui a fantastic underr student um
who is uh going into a graduate program
soon and the second part uh has was just
submitted a few weeks ago uh with uh
with yaj and a naray and gend
issue all right so here is what I would
I was hoping to be a take home message
of of the seminar today and and and um
the GPD pin to pin is what RBM is to Fem
so we have the finement method we
solving you know equations and uh in the
multiquery setting uh that the wrong
people we all care about uh there's a
you know one particular method is called
reduce basis method and in the you know
today's world uh we we we use neur
Network for things um uh you know with
find waving fashion let's say you know
the pin is is basically also a PD Sol um
and gpdp is basically a a a extension of
RBM to the to the to the pins to
Scientific machine learning um field um
so this a little bit of diagram is uh is
the overo
message his outline I will give you a
brief intro of the so-called pmo
projection based model order reduction
and then I spend a slide on on pins um
and then talk about you know how um how
we go from pin to uh to G GPD
pin and and and and then show you some
result for the gbd pin and find it again
from um the linear non linear extension
so the multiquery setting I'm pretty
sure you know this community is quite
familiar with um so here we have
simulations aerodynamic simulation or
maybe you know the radar signature type
of simulation we we need to change
things maybe the shape of the car right
or the flow field or angle material of
of the fighter jet all those things and
um and you want to optimize um the the
the the aerodynamic performance of the
vehicle or the the the the the radar
signature to minimize that of of your of
your object by tweaking your input the
shape on all those that were just
mentioned or perhaps you know um you
want to perform sensitivity analysis you
so all these situation you need to solve
um a parametrical system over and over
so you need
to the forward sve has be performed many
many many
times and and we cannot really afford to
you know always use the for model to for
for those forward solve so this is a
quick slide on on on the p uh with a you
know some references and here what I'm
showing you is a is a electromagnetic
problem and uh and what you will disc
discretize the domain and you see the
you know a lot of triangles on the on
the on the surface and that's basically
to there's a large number of degrees of
freedom to show those D
freedom and and and the the projection
based Modo reduction um strives to
accelerate this simulation so in
particular for the for the
RBM the linear reduction here is the
particular answers so what it does is
that it explores the par parameter
domain and find a few representative
parameter values um and then you you you
use your favorite forward order model a
full order model to solve for the
solution at those locations so those are
the other solutions that I use that I'm
giving here the U1 U2 u3 and for the for
the other parameter values you try to
come up with a surrogate so here is a a
linear
combination um with of your you know pre
selected precomputed
Solutions and the the the task then is
of course how do you find those um n n
dimensions and and and precomputed
solutions and on top of that given those
how do you calculate the the
coefficients C1 C2
C3 um I'm going to sh some light on
those so this this you give me me I
calculate this this C's C1 C2 to CN I'm
calling that a parameter to code map
um so the for the for the pmo um what I
mean there are certainly other methods
how you calculate this C Maybe by
interpolation or you know um a learning
but uh the traditional pmo uh is based
on solving the PD on in the in the in
the reduce setting so here's what I'm
trying to emphasize is in B physics so
we have a we have equation simple
reaction diffusion equation I'm taking
mu um as as as the two parameters
and the the the weak solution for the PD
is you know the we we look for solution
in the h10 space we solve the you know
the the the the the weak
formulation and final element is uh is
describing is discretizing the space h10
by a a finom space
VH perhaps a linear a piecewise
polinomial for example and it discretize
the by linear form a by a basically
numerical differentiation numerical
integration and by doing that you're
looking you're you're solving a you know
atiz formulation um and in in another
space in the space VH you go from h10 to
VH so the redu basis I'm using very
Loosely the term structure
preserving the the Rel Bas is one step
toward along this line so it looks for a
another space which I'm calling WN WM W
is a sub Subspace of VH other than that
and then of course the test function is
in the this conforming method in the
same space other than that there's no
change you solve this the same
formulation by by that's what I Loosely
meant by structure uh preserving there's
no you know I'm not talking about
physical structure
preserved so that's that's you know the
traditional final element the reduce
basis method and there's a a bit of
theory behind all that uh the key
concept of the chor grow and wids so
essentially what it does it it measures
to what extent you know your your your
manifold Your solution manifold you U by
going through all the different mu value
in your parameter domain how that
solution manifold can be approximated by
n dimensional space xn you take the
distance and then you you yeah you you
find the best possible PA in
theory and this distance of course is
defined in know um this way and for for
for many problems especially problem
with a bit diffusion so these uh n wids
Decay fast exponentially fast so that
would allow us to to come up with a
space w n that that uh
that would approximate the original
finan space really well and that's you
know you you give it hope that you can
find a really good
surrogate so the key question of how do
you construct that space WM all right um
um there's a you know widely used method
called pod um the Pod type of approaches
what it does is you sample your your mu
domain as sample
um like let's say you know a lot um and
then you do your you know your your SVD
and you basically then you truncate down
the keyword is truncate down you you
know you maybe you have 10,000 Solutions
snapshots and you truncate you take you
know the first 10 right for example so
you ended up using a lot more than the
you ended up quering the for model a lot
more times than the one you obtained in
the end um so that 10,000 is much larger
than 10 that's what I'm trying to say
here so that's that's a a perhaps a top
down approach you go you know you you
you you sum a lot and then you you cut
down and the RB is is uh is is uh
advocating for a a something called
greedy algorithm um so what it does is
is is a botton up so we we go from empty
set to the release basis uh
space um which I will describe more
later in the in the GPT pin setting um
the end result is that if you only need
10 Dimension space in the end you only
by the time you construct your space you
only have qu 10 times of your for model
um so that's a big difference so that's
a message that I'm trying to emphasize
here the amount of form data for the
model data is going from Big to small by
going from p to
RB and going back to the the the key
part of you know the p2c map from me Toc
mu certainly have been other approaches
the new network type approaches and I'm
listing just a few of them and
that by far not complete list and
started from around 2018 is um by Hasen
group The
pnn and uh there was um and this is a
lark paper by carbook and and
co-authors um proposing the auto encoder
in in this uh reduction
setting and the the you know the overall
message here is that
um once you train the map from me to C
mu you give me a new me I simply
evaluate the map the train map so map
recovered via direct evaluation of FN
direct evaluation direct evaluation
and and I want to point out there's a
nice uh theoretical paper here and what
what is they essentially proved is that
um for problem where RBM Works basically
there is a a low rank structure that
exist a a DNN that will that can
approximate this solution map to to to
to your accuracy and furthermore they
proved the the Upp bound of the size of
the DNN uh is essentially the cubic of
the of the intr intrinsic
Dimension that's a nice work
there um so I'm trying to put this
methods in in a in in know um uh the C
catalog them the P why I put it here
meaning um meaning that you know you you
need more you need more data so the
horizontal axis is amount of data
vertical AES is amount of physics um the
reduced model is based on the PD so
there there's physics in in it the NM
regression uh you need data because you
train the map by the label data so you
you train that's a data intensive
approach in
general and uh and as the end result uh
there's no physics in when you give me
mu I give you the the the C mu RBM is
sort of in the second quadrant um
perhaps a more more preferred one you
you need less form data while um having
more physics
encoded and speaking of you know
numerical solvable there's a there's a
that since 20189 there is a a family of
method called pin physics inform form
neuronet work um so what it does is uh
is it has this complicated function
right it's a linear operation composed
with
nonlinear uh functions and keep keep
doing that and and and and uh and you
basically use that as your solution to a
PD and what what you do then is you use
the the magic of Auto differentiation
and uh and and and you calculate a loss
uh a point value a point pointwise loss
the cocation
setting and the the the new network then
trains those way W and bios B um or
maybe there's something in the sigma the
non linear activation function train all
that by minimizing this this uh this
loss this loss this loss not only
contains the the PD the res the residual
but also the deviation of your solution
with boundary condition and initial
condition so in a way it satisfy PD and
also the boundary each conditions uh you
know you train it until your Ms is small
enough or maybe you cannot decrease it
anymore and you take that SATA as your
as your you know as your as your um
network configuration and that Network
function is then your PD solution right
so simple but um powerful and popular
idea so of course as somebody in the
Rong Community right once you know I saw
this I was like okay what do we do when
you need to solve a parameter dependent
equation of course to people in pin you
you you could just add a me here as a
input right so that's one way to do it
but the out the drawback is you are
introducing a larger uh Network um and
and and uh um training takes more time
or or all that um you know
disadvantages um so if we just look at
if we don't do that approach and we have
this you know every time you have me you
train your SATA the network uh
configurations and the challenges of
trying to work with that is is we
observed there's a you know that there's
not really a low rank structure within
your SATA we we showed a graph uh in the
paper
um and that's what I just mentioned um
so so some some related attempts and
again this by far not a complete list so
I'm I'm
listing a few of them so the first one
is B basically to play with this those
SATA star and uh you know you you you do
regression interpolation type of things
in your parameter space and and you take
the traditional meta learning approaches
I'm calling pin plus X so the x is is
whatever approach you do with with your
SATA
star
and and but again that related with you
know there is no good low rank structure
from what we observed um the second is a
Depon and F and O um so this is a more P
based thinking so you you and it's data
driven and again once you train it it
basically just evaluate the the the map
and The Meta know is taking on um a more
transfer learning approach um and again
the Sate is fully data driven
uh a more recent one is called P RNN by
by by Chen one has Haven and John um and
and they introduced
um basically to you know to not purely
data driven but also to incorporate a
bit physics in that training in the
training of the map again once you have
you train the map you know you give me
new mu is still evaluate evaluate of the
train
map so this is this is what I'm
summarizing here all those method is
sort of in the in the fourth quadrant um
is you need more data and uh the the the
end result is a is a is a map that you
evaluate for a given me and pi and N I'm
put it in the third quadrant here takes
a bit less data and so the question for
me to ask was what about this second
quadrant can we in in this setting can
we do something with um less data but
more
physics and that's what I'm trying to
argue here that's where GPT pin uh
belongs and now the design of the GPT
pin so what what I'm going back to you
know where I started from the redu basis
method so that's what inspired this
whole thing and this is the an of the r
basis um so you are taking a linear
combination of of your precomputed and a
well chosen uh uh
solution and now you know the first step
is of course if you use
pin you just replace that Solution by
the pin right and what this is if you
you know you take a look it's
just a a a a one layer zero bias uh a
network you take linear combination you
plus
zero and N is certainly the width of
this layer and uh I C I think of as the
weight and slightly interesting one is
this uh this pin the p c i right the I
pin it for the whole netw work this this
I pin is essentially a activation
function but it's not you know the the
regular ones regular um or all that it's
it's not those you have to put it you
you have to put a a customized
activation function so to
speak so that's what we did we uh you
know we we have this uh reduced Network
so it's basically only
two something n one
network and uh you you give me XT um I
have you know in the one hidden layer
right one hidden layer the hid layer has
n networks each neuron is full
Network and then I put the weight here
and I combine them to get my reduced
solution so the the the the the
generative part um is that you give me a
new me right so in parametric setting
you give me me I basically generate a a
a a this network this reduce solution
for you um there you know one one um
point to point out one thing to point
out is that the MU comes in as the um as
as a loss function you give me new me
the MU decides otherwise the whole
network is independent of mu right it
looks um potentially confusing but uh
where the MU comes in is through the the
loss the loss of of of the network so
give me new mu that defines a loss for a
particular loss for the network and then
the network goes ahead and train those
SE those weights that's uh this is this
simple idea um and and the the these
guys are are are pre-trained so
pre-trained pins pre-trained and you put
it there training takes time but once
you train it you put them as a as a
neuron as activ activation the
evaluation takes you know is is
quick so the next point is that these
guys are growing one by one just like a
greedy that I was describing for f for
for redu bases so we started by a 211
Network and then it grows to 221 231
and all the way to two N1 I'm going to
describe uh the greedy algorithm
later um so the sort of the features it
inad physics CA the loss all right that
you train the network by minimizing
decreasing the loss the loss has has has
a residual and the boundary and each
condition in it and in small form data
is a again is a is a ground La approach
uh it starts with with empties and then
goes one two three um it's not top- down
approach and it has um metan neurons so
by by by what we meant you know just
each the activation is full Network so
it's a network of network uh
approach and it non-intrusive uh by by
which I meant um is you don't need the
knowledge of of the pin so we have
example where we tested on alanc we use
self adaptive pin we don't need to know
know what's going on inside those
neurons in the in in the one hidden
layer there and just like you know other
wrong method it accelerate the the
underlying method here it accelerate the
pin uh the marginal acceleration is two
to three a magnitude just again like you
know what we see for the traditional RBM
uh type of
result and and and before showing you
result I want to mention you know just a
couple of things one is that the success
of this is
largely um based on the the derivatives
are
linear and and the pin the whole pin
thing is is collocation is collocation
nature right um so it's more is more
local and and those things allow us to
um to precompute um so just just like um
you know wrong approaches is offline
online um setting um
stages and here we precompute the
quantities that that we need uh for
online so that's important important
piece and another one to connect with
with RBM which will allow me to describe
the the the gdy aggon that I promise you
um is is this a postor estimator so
that's a key element for for Rel bases
you need that to explore your uh
solution solution space to identify the
next uh uh sampling point and and and
that's you know in RB for people who
know F element that that's you know more
or less straightforward because
basically the standard resid residual
based AR estimation is scaled by um you
know your your stability
constant and and and um and if if we
think about the the neuron networ the
pins um
the loss is based on the residual so the
the MSE that I talk about so we sort of
have
a have a automatic Choice there so take
the loss of the reduced Network that's a
residual based indicator right um so
that's what I'm going to to
use so here is a flowchart so we have uh
we we set it up you have you have just
like uh the typical ROM you need a you
need to develop for the model uh here I
have a four pin ready ready to go all
right and uh and and and in the
beginning I know nothing about my uh
solution manifold so I just pick my
first one randomly all right
and and and then I solve a full pin at
this one point mu1 okay now you have one
pin so you can construct a 2 one1
Network and is one so it's a little
Network walk 211 with one one neuron in
the middle um and then you go you go
train it you go train this 211 Network
everywhere you sort of use your current
reduced model to explore your space
everywhere so every time I include I I
record my my code I include my loss this
is residual based loss all right and the
greedy the greedy step is that well I
take a look at all those loss
um over the whole parameter domain is
that you know small enough of course
when is two on one is likely it's not so
it's not small enough so I'm going to
take the one this greedy idea the one
that maximizes my um my arror estimator
arror
indicator and that's where I'm going to
sample next right this a classic greedy
algorithm has quite a bit of Sil behind
so once I determined my me2 I go ahead
and and call my full pin again at Z mu2
so now I have my second pin so my 211
Network became a 221 and then I repeat
this uh loop I go from 221 to 31 to 41
and so on so forth and until hopefully
at some point this U Global uh uh uh uh
the maximum loss over the paramet domain
is uh less than uh tolerance then then
we stop we take that as a as a um gbdp
uh uh
Network so we tested this thing on um
three examples the burgers and Alan Khan
and uh Clan Gordon so they have uh
respectively one two three parameter
values
um and this is just you know the setup
in the interest time I'm going to not
dive into the details here um I'm going
to show you the result of of of of one
equation so here is a bogus the bogus
equation um and the first one is where
the the networks decided to sample so we
started not exactly random but just take
the middle of the perimet domain um and
then you you you you generate let that
decide what to do next you see it goes
to number two number three and then sort
of focus more toward you know the lower
uh viscosity end and picked one here um
so in the end we showed you know this
largest loss graph as you proceed this
process from one to N9 neurons so in the
very end we only have nine neutrons in
the hidden layer and the black curve
here is where is our method um so we get
below um two digits which is sort of um
you know in the in the pin setting um
is is is um is about about okay and just
to show how powerful this idea of this
RB ROM idea is um when basically move to
the pin setting if we do a uniform
sampling new uniform soal uniform
neurons here we just uniformly sample
the parameter domain and just call and
train them and put them at the hidden
layer and it's not bad um you know it's
worse than the Adaptive One but not not
not not that bad this is more statistics
um of of of the losses and I'm just
showing you the three uh the first three
modes that was calculated by the gbt pin
so to test that we tested on a number of
uh unseen parameter values but still
within the the range of the that it was
trained um so it you know it it um does
performance reasonable really well with
with again the terminal arrrow with um
at the end of the training and to show
the the computational saving what I'm
showing here is as the XX is a test case
number so we repeatedly call so here the
the red curve is if you repeatedly call
your PIN um for you know up to 25 times
and you you re you record the uh
cumulative running time all right so for
the GPD pin um you know you have this
initial initial investment where you you
train it you you form your your tpd PIN
afterwards this the slope is basically
flat um the slope you know measure the
margin of time right so the the slope
ratio is more than 100 so you know two
mag to all of the magnitud speed up and
but of course just like other you know
uh R approaches you know you this for M
query so if you need to basically need
more queries than this intersection
point right you need more than that
number of um for this implementation in
more than that number of queries is
worthwhile to to um to invest in the in
the in the learning
stage so for the other two equations we
we got very similar result I'm just
showing you some nice pictures of the of
the of the other two
equations and the speed up factor is uh
more than the bogus and and just to
repeat myself so the the Allan equation
we used a self adaptive pin um um
developed by these colleagues and um we
don't need to get into the pin just you
know take it and and run it at where the
gbdp nron ask us to train and that's
it so I want to spend uh perhaps the
remaining time in to talk about the
extension to the the nonlinear reduction
setting the what what um we were call in
the ttbd pin so where we bring back the
N wids so this
um for again for diffusion type of
problem um that was a result that
basically shows you know there's a low
rank structure so the this uh this n
wids decreases exponentially
fast which allows us to construct a a a
a a a small space to approximate the
solution manifold right um but for
transport dominated phenomenon so here
what what I meant is you you you sample
a long time just above the same thing if
you sample a long time there's a low
rank structure here for the transport if
if it's some a long time um you know
it's a it's it's just like identity
Matrix is the same thing moving forward
um you don't really you don't really get
a low R structure um if you do SVD to to
The Matrix and in fact um it can be
proven that this instead of upper bound
like the diffusion setting for transport
dominating situation there's a lower
bound so your your we will be not will
will not Decay faster than that than
this a fairly slow
Decay so that that's um the the the main
H for um the linear reduction and uh the
the reason for colleague to start
working on nonlinear reduction in the in
the last few
years so we just very briefly what we
did is we incorporated this this not a
new idea Incorporated with this
transform idea I'm listing again a
partial list of of of of of um result in
the last few years so what we did is um
it's basically we're adding a layer
adding a layer of this uh transforms the
transform blocks to to to the gbt gbt
pin and for you see the you know each
transform for each mu mu I have a
transform and uh that that that's that's
it that's it I'm going to show you some
result to you know to demonstrate how it
it works but the key Point here is that
once you have this structure defined um
you give me a new me
um the the the weights the C's that that
were that were in the GPD pin and the
transforms were simultaneous trained um
by this reduced
Network and it's still in the in in the
pin setting in the pin fashion meaning
um the PD is incorporated as as a loss
function and uh and this is basically a
a non nonlinear RB um by incorporating
this um this this transform before um
putting it into the
pins and that was you know you know
recently submitted uh on
paper so to show you how how it works um
here is a is a result from the welper
2017 paper this is a function is a
pretty nasty function so this is some of
the snapshots as you change the new
value so you see first of all they all
have
discontinuity and some of the
discontinuity is on the left some of the
discontinuity is on the right right and
uh and moreover the discon continuity
moves as you change the me all right um
so this is a typical challenging setting
for that that calls for nonlinear
reduction so here I'm showing you some
result uh the gray is the exact solution
if we do you know textbook like range
interpetation um you you you get this is
you know the the the the the S tools
right and and in in mod reduction
settings there something called eim
empirical interpretation method um what
it does is it uses this this same family
this same members of the same family to
interpolate to use them as bases to I'm
going to pick just like RB I'm going to
pick mu1 me2 M three and so on I
generally you want you to use three use
those as basis as opposed to perhaps you
know um the the the
promals and that's that's a that's a
purpose thing you you you can you still
cannot avoid void the the the S tools
but if you apply
the soal GT gbdp idea you get basically
identical um um approximation a perfect
approximation um because the idea is it
it it it detects and automatically lined
up the disc continuity once the dis
discontinuity is lined up then you can
do your your lineing combination that
would be more
effective
and um so we appli that to a few pdes
and I'm showing you one result here uh
is a nonlinear reaction uh equation so
we are able to solve the family of
equations the parametric PD uh you one
using one neuron one big neuron right um
it's one neuron but this whole pin as
one neuron um so that's a nonlinear the
T gptp result if we were to use the
original gptp
um you know you would need need 10 but
even with 10 the the the the the the the
the the the result is worse than the
nonlinear result with one
neuron um so to conclude um we we have
the first pin accelerator um which is um
the RBM is um you know what we believe
is the first P accelerator that that is
follows the wrong idea the RBM
framework um that preserve the pin
structure um relies on on you know less
data and uh it's non inclusive it's sort
of um you know you you pull existing pin
you can just plug it to your to your
network um the loss is uh is uh you know
is is Guided by the grid
construction and uh it naturally
features offline online decomposition um
and uh realizing actual speed up in
practice and uh we extend it to the to
the uh nonlinear reduction
setting so um you know the the code is
is is available on GitHub and uh here my
email and I also want to acknowledge
funding support from from um SF F osr
and uh and the mass program at OS and uh
we have a a pretty active um Center for
scientific computer data science
research um so acknowledge all you know
appreciate all those support and thank
you everyone for your attention to the
talk today thank you thank you so much
for the wonderful talk a beautiful idea
I I especially like the the fact that
you combine the video spaces uh the
framework and you know with the pins
idea awesome wonderful job okay let's
have a Q&A sessions um if you have
question questions please unmute
yourself and ask
questions uh maybe I can start um you
know the pins beautiful
idea very popular problem with the pins
though
is uh the fact that they impose the
boundary condition and initial
conditions in weekly like in the um loss
functions one of the loss functions yeah
but I mean for one problem that's that's
okay but if you go to 2D 3D and then you
know complex
geometry uh no longer a trivial um task
to imposing those uh boundary condition
and initial condition and your
framework um you know basically relying
on the original pins framework right
right yeah so it you know those issues
with the pins import the boundary
condition initial
condition your method has that too
because we are using relying on the
original things if you can comment on
that yeah it basically inherits inherits
the advantages but also the
disadvantages of pins right um a lot of
uh can you know is Up For Debate um I
think you know to implement it uh in 2D
3D um is is is you know people certainly
did it right in terms of accuracy and
and and U speed comparing with the
traditional methods that's a different
story uh it's doable uh I guess the the
the I there's a there's a method called
a
variational pin and with which I am not
familiar um we know in the traditional
numerical method sometimes you don't
want to you don't want to uh um uh
enforce your boundary conditions in a
strong fashion and that would change
that would have negative impact on the
on the the converion speed for example
the converion order
[Music]
um so yeah so maybe some of those you
know we have to go through the more Gan
and more variational
approach for for for to to to to uh
overcome some of those disadvantages but
yeah you know the over message exactly
right you know so um you know this
inherits the the whole the whole frame
is a is a is a pink flavor in in the in
the reduced level so it it cares pretty
much everything from
there yeah
yeah beautiful idea though y um thank
you is there any question from
audience otherwise I can keep
asking uh master
yes you unmute yourself you want to ask
yeah yeah yeah just a quick question
um so in in the the word rvm you like
like like many other you know
Frameworks there is the challenge of
with with with uh with dimensionality
right uh meaning I mean the curse of
dimensionality you know uh and forgive
me this this could be a you know kind of
naive question
but combining RBM and
pain um I'm not saying you have tried it
I'm not even saying you have thought
about it but are there ways to to
benefit from this
combination
right
um to alleviate right the the challenge
with C of dimensionality
uh and and the reason I I I asked that
question is you you do know that there
are problems where where we have many
many parameters and for example you do
know like there is for example to
topology optimization where you have
like you know thousands of you know
uh
parameters and
uh yeah I mean it's just you know I'm
just thinking out loud and I yeah that's
certainly
a a a tough problem um I think and a lot
of people have been working on it um I
mean the in terms of in the vanilla RB
um and and so the vanila gbdp let's say
uh we we want to make sure the parameter
domain is well covered so you are doing
um um you know a c condition grid let's
say on the on the primary domain and of
course then you have the exponential
increase the cality of your of your test
of your training set with exponential
increase with the number of parameters
um the training offline training because
every time you're exploring the domain
so the training is linear with with
respect to the cardinality of your
training
set um last things we can sort of do to
delay the not overcome but delay the
customer dimensionality maybe you want
to you know we have some result I think
including young group has some result in
perhaps you know some some smart way of
sampling or maybe you introduce maybe a
gradient based approaches uh we had some
result uh a few years back you know we
can reconstruct you know we we we based
on a a fine something but then with one
uh with one um swimming uh we can
reconstruct a sort of a more you know
area where you want to explore keep
exploring and those areas you know you
explore why don't need to explore again
your next 3D step but all that is at the
most delay is a c of dimensionality
dimensionality yeah yeah
yeah that's tough tough
one than thank you you thank
you uh related to that if you can go to
slide 11 y name
okay
all right so where are we
now a lot of
sles yeah oh awesome okay yeah here IBM
um
needs less number of data because you
know greedy approach greedy algorithm
you know the Pod you can also apply the
greedy sampling that way you can reduce
the amount of the flo model data then
you can move the Pod to the the same
category of the same of the yeah yeah I
guess by this I me the vanilla version
yeah point I know for uh uh uh um um um
like you work on
theity right for example
is gity
gity we have both of yeah yeah yeah
exactly the vanilla version right
is got it got it thank you thank
you all right is there any other
questions so what is the next step um
you obviously want to um you know makes
the problem more complex like instead of
1D you you may want to extend it to 2D
and then 3D and
Etc yeah that's certainly a a very
worthy uh Direction so right now we're
focusing
on um to go toward the nonlinear
Direction a bit more so right now we
with with the nonlinear the tgb idea
works you know for like for transport I
didn't show the result here but for
transport is in the paper for for linear
transport you know you you you you one
neon you get machine accuracy basically
comparing with the four model um for
other things like nonlinear reaction
diffusion um um um and then you know we
with with some convection um um you know
they work out well for burgers um and
we're trying to do o equation um so the
for those ones uh the the transform
blocks are not that easy to to handle so
right now uh the transform is
simply a a fine transform you have a
fine in each block of the transform
layer that's uh good enough for for a
lot of equations but for not the case
for you know uh in viscus I mean for in
viscus bookus is still good enough for
the the REM problem for example or the
different um REM problems and for Oiler
that's challenging even even for the
underlying pin um so you know that's
what we're currently working on now I
see yeah high dimension is certainly a
challenge um yeah yeah it's challenge
for pin and it's certainly a challenge
for the any other data driven
approach data driven approach right
that's
yeah may I have a question yeah sure go
ahead yeah hello y nice to see
your hi
Yu on phone from MP
monb yeah um so my question is that
um uh so you use the uh shift to
transform the uh coordinate and time uh
but it's different from other work
because for other work they also use
some kind of construction to return back
to the unshifted uh coordinate system so
but H it seems to me that you you shift
the coordinate uh and then you you you
you just work simply uh in the shifted
coordinate system and
the the the the Reconstruction step in
the original coordinate system is
missing uh from the from your overall
Network I don't know what's what's the
difference from your uh overall Network
U from the other existing Network yeah
in terms of um in terms of the shifting
idea and and the scaling right in terms
of that uh nothing is new so we
basically just Incorporated that idea uh
to the pin and the gbt pin setting so
included that in as an addition layer so
yeah so I listed some reference there
certainly that idea is not new
um yes
um so from other work they they they
they have two steps shifting and
reconstruction yeah but it seems to me
you you have shifting and then you work
simply uh in the shifted coordinate
system so I don't know whether whether
your your your pins the GPT pins already
uh
implicitly
yeah included this reconstruction step
certainly yes yes yes I miss that that
part yeah yeah yeah um so you know if we
go back to the first layer the input
layer right it's kind of like that's
that's the Second Step you go back to
the original
coordinate so the is defined from the
original input layer X before the shift
okay evaluation from the h thing means
means a reconstruction yeah okay okay
thank you yeah thank
you awesome is there any other question
from
audience
well if not let's thank our uh wonderful
speaker Yan thank you so much Yan for
the um a great idea and great talk um we
were able to follow it very easily you
have a great presentation skill as well
thank you so much yome and thank you
everyone for for for tuning in today I
appreciate your attention all right
thank you so much take care take
care uh um Yan are you still there yeah
uh would you mind sharing the slide with
me of course yeah I can awesome yeah of
course not I mean I I'll send to you you
so okay thank you all right keep in test
byebye
bye